so i know you've been into that kind of
[ __ ] like alexander the great yeah
all the all the different conquerors
guys pippin
charlemagne clovis
now is this stuff that you just studied
because you wanted to study conquerors
that just interest you
i wanted to study that mindset
you know and um i found that the
greatest conquerors
that ever lived um
the farmers you know farmers
sheepherders somebody that we wouldn't
think that's important
and stuff and then as they became great
through that
they may gave birth to great children
who were born with greatness like
alexander the great and stuff like
philip the macedonian
that whole bloodline of alexander they
were all kings but they were very small
and insignificant
until um it was always one alexander
before him that was
pretty great and fought against the
persians but eventually they lost
and they pretty much kissed the
persian's ass you know i mean the
persians put them in a position
of power until um philip of phillip
macedonia came
who had the nickname aka philip the
barbarian
and he wanted to go across and enslave
all the persians and everybody after
that the world
and alexander the great mother who was a
really interesting woman
um
i'm trying to say albanian maybe and
they had a different kind of um
study and worship and stuff back then so
he got caught up in that
his family didn't like her for that but
um
she arranged for she arranged for
alexander's father i think to be killed
for alexander to have the power then her
kick says
the power she could lead to her kids
while he was on campaigns
right and um
when he was on these campaigns now that
his father was going he just
conquered everything but when he ran
into the afghani people
he fell in love with them he wanted to
breed with him he wanted to create a new
race of afghan he is madly fell in love
with him
and that's pretty much why his his
family is not saying but the
greeks went um what they went mountain
mutiny on him because they were jealous
that they were given
big positions to the um the persians
no afghanistan he loved him he even
quote afghanistan the most beautiful
people of the world god must have loved
them more than anybody
he made them beautiful he really fell in
love with them
when did you start getting really into
like conquerors when you start 15.
you're 15 yeah what what introduced you
to it um i was at the table eating with
custard and a friend of mine named craig
wolfe said
a statement which was wrong but it
sounds really good to make me
investigate
he said alexander the great at his time
was like six five so at six
five three hundred years before christ
that was a giant which was wrong he was
very
small the arm was too big for him he's a
very small guy
he wasn't big at all and so
just that alone him saying that got you
interesting yeah i wanted him
after he was the monk he's a massive guy
but i found that he's just a small man
average guy you know he's not a mac
monster at all
not a big man at all but you got
interested in the
the mindset of the conquerors listen
this is what i want to know
why would one person think that he could
[ __ ] own the whole world
one person why would he have that mind
who would think like that
right why would a man person why would
that's not a [ __ ] person that's just
something
when your egos just got so out of whack
yeah well you just
you just can't think rational how do you
think like that
and you're a nice person it was a guy
before him a couple hundred years before
him named
cyrus the great he was just like he was
a conqueror but he was a conqueror for
liberty
he wanted to conquer all slaves and let
them go conquer all slave masters let
them go he got killed for that too but
team who maybe that sounds that sounds
cool too right
that's good that's a good thing but
listen think about it who the [ __ ] is he
to take somebody else's property take
somebody else's stuff because he believe
it's wrong which it probably is wrong i
think it's wrong
but who the [ __ ] is he right who is this
guy to take others just to
conquer you you don't bother nobody but
this is what they did back there now
you're killing everybody back then
it was really legal it's almost in the
bibles and the books
it's not i won't say but it's in books
slavery it's in the books in the
religious book that we need slaves and
he did this
and this guy's gonna say hey no more
slaves
he's 500 b.c so he's going to say no
more slaves
no more slavery is wrong out through the
whole world so he wants to conquer the
world and free of slaves
wow so that's just a different mindset
yeah the different
kinds of mindsets that these conquerors
have but who doesn't know who
he thinks he is who the hell is he he
has this little town over here he's
gonna go over the whole world his town
is right here
well forget his town his country is
right here
yeah you know and he don't even he
didn't even conquer this country there
now he's gonna conquer the world and
liberate free to make freedom what kind
of
no that's nothing if that's not somebody
on drugs you don't you tell me
no you tell me now be honest that's not
somebody's high you tell me it could be
coke
no that [ __ ] it's something it's
something
i'm a free everybody right this is the
one at 500 bc this is
slavery is what it is this is the way of
the world no i'm gonna free all the
slaves
that's pretty crazy like everybody
what did you get out of like reading
about their mindset like studying
temujin
studying alexander the great like what
did you get out of reading their
about their mindsets um
i found out that the greatest ones the
best
the most prolific ones
were all mama's boys really yeah afraid
of their mother
wow napoleon alexander
you know what i mean wow
genghis khan too yeah really yeah
what do you what do you think that is
huh what do you think that's all about
highly respect their mother i'm not
thinking they're
um i think their mothers were the first
especially alexander the great
i think she was the first stage mother i
think there was some before her too
you know because cleopatra was one
that's just what they were at they said
they were they were wanting to lead
through their sons or their
daughters or something like that oh okay
like like that parent that takes their
kids to athletic events and
screams and cheers and pumps them up and
no no no no no it's the parent who
whose child word is law and i want to be
able to have that
word um okay do you get that yeah
my son is the king right this country a
couple of countries
but i want i want i want my thought to
be in his mind come out of his mouth do
you think the parents
convinced the child that they were that
special that they should run the world
some of them do but as some kids get
older like ivan the great having the
terrible
they get older and then they realize
these people weren't right to me and i
and they start killing his
sponsors of the people that would rip
his step parents and stuff
you know some of the kings did it too
you know so when when you were studying
this when you were
coming up as a boxer and you're studying
all these conquerors
you were trying to understand their
mindsets yeah and you were trying to
apply that to your own life
pretty much yeah did you get anything
out of it yeah
yeah yeah what did what did you get like
what how did it apply to your own life
well at the end of the day i'll ask god
for forgiveness
all of them
so when you're reading all these books
about all these conquerors when you're a
young man and you're on your way to
becoming the youngest ever heavyweight
champion
and you you're trying to take on the
mindset of the conquerors and you find
out they all ask god for forgiveness
yes how did that affect you that was
pretty cool
um because by that i learned
greatness was the willingness to die
by you know doing researching on these
particular individuals
and that's what they were willing to do
for greatness
um and you know you heard about achilles
and stuff he said he
what does he want a a short life of um
of greatness then a long life of
obscurity
yeah he took the short life and that's
what alexander did
when you when you study these people and
you uh
you you take that conqueror's mindset
did you get anything out of that did you
apply that into your own
your own pursuit as a champion
absolutely because you have to
listen alexander the great was 32 and he
conquered the known world
yeah in 10 years
and so thinking about that as a as a
young man absolutely
i want um i want my preeminence to rival
the time that
you know in the sands of time it's not
rain with it
i think everybody should want that that
are competitive
in the art of um what do you say
immortality yeah and i searched for it
that's what he wanted he wanted he
wanted immortality that's what he wanted
he wanted to be known since you know
till the end of time
did you ever think that maybe you were
born in the wrong time that maybe if you
were born in the times of alexander the
great you would also be a conqueror
no i am a conqueror now because i have
conquered myself and my
demons you know not because i'm at that
time i'm never born to i'm born in the
right time
most of them couldn't conquer their
demons
that's why they asked for forgiveness
from god all of them
because just like um
the gentleman um that discovered um
um alcohol is anonymous you know
he um he inspired maybe he maybe he had
a problem with alcohol at the end
but how many people have he inspired
yeah that is so much bigger than him
succeeding or not with his problem
you know what's interesting about him is
uh he
was interested in lsd bill wilson yeah
yeah that was a big thing of his
that's what that's what instructed him
to have the program yeah
to develop the program yeah when you're
talking about they all
would seek forgiveness from god that's
it's so interesting to me that you
turned to cannabis and cannabis will
allowed you to forgive yourself
yeah i'm listen the reason why they
asked for forgiveness for god this is
why this is
interesting that you said that it's
because they believed they were god
and they had at the end of the day
realize and check themselves but they're
not
yeah they're not god and then they've
done horrific things oh
yeah at the end of his life he was so
forgiving and giving everything away and
so sorry for everything he didn't know
how to forgive himself either he didn't
know
how do you do that when you think you go
how do you forgive yourself so at the
end of the day he said look the man who
conquered the world
died with nothing in his hand he gave
everything away he had no swords or
nothing
he was so freaked out about dying being
the rich guy and stuff and having so
much property and having the world like
he
possessed because he had the world it's
this gentleman that he
well you genius forgot the guy that they
named sloth after
the animal sloth eugenius i don't know
but he was like he's considered a
homeless bum
nowadays today he would be called obama
homeless guy or whatever
and alexander been watching him this is
how keen he is he's watched this guy
for years and he said listen before he
became king of greece he's watched this
guy
this is where he went the camera and he
said hey listen
i watch you and i have everything and
i'm unhappy and you don't have nothing
so
what can i do to you to make you happy
you know what he said
nobody had the balls to say he said
first of all you can be kind enough to
move out the way of the son
and then allowed me to enjoy my day
and he couldn't conceive of somebody to
turn him down for riches and stuff he
couldn't conceive of it it just blew his
mind
he was so blown away he couldn't even
kill the guy for disrespecting them he
was just blown away
he said this i have everything and i
didn't realize he wasn't happy he had it
all
he's the king of greece he didn't even
know where he was getting ready to go he
didn't mean to be king of the world but
he
reason he's just not happy and he has
everything
so he thinks by conquering the world
it's going to make him happy
and he did and he what happened he
turned into a drug
wow imagine that
it's crazy he ran that's what he
experienced with new drugs he listened
when um
when you went on a campaign know what i
thought i thought when you went on the
campaign
the movies lie they say you go on a
campaign that's just about
300 gladiators or whatever 10 000 so you
know they bring their whole family with
them
it's like a party their wives their kids
everything they got the um surveyors
with them um house builders are with
them
the people who deal with um agriculture
for that time
everything's with the wine even for they
could test everything when they conquer
conquering you know what conquering is
we think that's glorious conquering this
glory and the why because now it is
conquering robbing rape and illegally
taking somebody else's goods and
enslaving them that's conquering
that's not good people all the people we
like
we say these guys this guy he conquered
this he conquered that
they hurt people they did it for greed
they didn't do it for
we're going to help our people they did
it to take things because they could
now when you were coming up as a fighter
and you were reading all these things
about conkers
you you were fueling your mind in that
way and you were also studying a lot of
fights
you studied all the old-school champions
are you doing that now in this
resurgence like are you studying
no because i think i know everything
about the movie i've did the research
no i was a kid so i started reading to
that i started going to the other leg
level so i go from the level of these
guys that are fighters
the gladiators all those guys so i go to
from them to the generals
and from the generals to the gods
and